if you want to hear the theory about how
everything in this movie ties back to
the original train crash in unbreakable
then stick around to the end of this
video welcome back to things you missed
and happy Halloween this will probably
be the last episode I get to put up this
October it went by so fast one thing
that did not go by fast was the way
between unbreakable and split that was a
16 year weights so with that in mind
waiting till January for the third movie
in the franchise glass to come out
doesn't seem as bad until then we've got
a second trailer and I've got some
things you missed you may have noticed
the strong color scheme on display in
glass
Elijah price has a lot of purples in his
clothes and his shoes in his stuff he's
the villain and the villain section in
the comic book store is purple and this
is also kind of his movie in the series
and all of the titles are purple to
signify that then there's the hoard and
his color is yellow like if you look at
his comic book pages the indicator
lights on these machines in his room and
almost all of his outfits some of the
rooms are either painted or lists to
match these colors and there is a line
suggesting that Elijah and the hoard
could team up that sounds like teaming
up which may be the reason that this
room is striped in yellow and purple
David Dunn is green the color of his
iconic rain poncho from the first movie
until now and the color of his outfit at
the mental institution it matches that
and the hero section of the comic book
store is green as well the respective
characters colors are made very obvious
in the poster though I do hope we get
another poster at some point with the
cracked glass on it to match up with the
split and unbreakable posters that fit
together and one laid out side by side
you can also see each of their colors
represented in different rooms on the
security monitors if you pause right
here you may be wondering why there's so
much focus on these colors I recommend
you go pay attention to the movies piece
no okay fine I think the colors are
there to represent David's innate
ability to sense evil he has this sense
a sixth sense if you will okay I really
have to stop trying to put jokes in my
videos in the first movie we see that if
David touches someone then he can see
the bad things that they've done he can
track bad people in a crowd because
their color will stand
to him and become much more saturated so
I think purple and yellow are there
villain colors as seen by David once
David and the Horde are captured and put
into the institution the woman studying
them her name's dr. staple has
individual methods for keeping them all
in check for Elijah they keep him
sedated because apparently he's become
such a good manipulator that they can't
even handle him if he's fully awake he's
too small David's room is filled with
these pipes and nozzles because his
weakness is water so they give him a
spray whenever he becomes unruly this
would also be an effective room for
scientists to study the aliens from
science don't you think the method that
they use to keep the Horde under control
is pretty much explained verbatim in the
trailer different identity to take when
I did the video talking about the first
glass trailer I wondered why dr. staple
didn't have the [ __ ] to chain down like
David done in this trailer you can see
that the flashing lights are set up
behind her so she can change him to a
different personality if things get
dicey the fact that these are the
weaknesses is very interesting to me and
here's why think back to unbreakable one
of the most iconic scenes in that movie
I mean heck one of the most iconic
scenes in cinema is the scene where he
rescues the kidnapped kids in the rain
almost drowning in the pool as he does
so
[Music]
that's an epic scene but imagine what
the final showdown could be like in
glass a fight breaks through the glass
window into a thunderstorm david is
dramatically weakened by the water but
the intermittent flashes of lightning
caused the hoarder to be constantly
changing personalities throwing him into
complete disarray so it'll come down to
Elijah to think of some clever solution
[Music]
when I did the things you missed on the
first glass trailer I broke down this
entire comic that appears on screen and
talked about how this character could
represent either the Horde or David
because of his a desire to protect
people in this trailer we get a glimpse
at another panel of this comic it says I
found to protect everyone from those of
us given these cruel gifts that line
suggest that this is more likely
representative of David why is it do you
think that of all the professions in the
world you chose protection however I
wouldn't also rule out the possibility
that this is a sign that the Beast will
change sides and realize that he wants
to be a good guy also I think they've
already learned their lesson about the
beasts ability to bend bars because it
looks like in his room
he's got bricks for windows next there's
a scene in which Elijah's sneaks into
the record room and accesses the hordes
medical file let's pause on that and
take a closer look you'll notice some of
the names of the identities familiar to
us from split such as raquel luke
pauline bernice and of course of the
beast we know this because each identity
has a file on the computer in split
however there are some new names here
like this name ending in Aleta and this
name ending in the letters ma so this
could be evidence that there are still
new personalities emerging within the
Horde just as the Beast emerged as a
24th personality back in splits speaking
of the Beast the first time Kevin's body
was transformed into the Beast was at
the train station in split the backstory
is glossed over and we find out in that
movie that Kevin's dad left on a train
when he was a child and never came back
leading some to believe that this
emotional damage caused the identity
disorder and some to theorized that the
train that he left on was Easter L 177
the train that crashed and left David
Dunn as the only survivor I bring this
all up because the new trailer reveals a
scene taking place in what appears to be
a hobo camp inside of a subway station
and the
is the one who's exploring it and
probably scaring the hobos so bad I mean
could you imagine hiding in an abandoned
tunnel and all of a sudden this
approaches you there is one other
possible callback hidden in this trailer
and that is when Elijah price is
addressing David at the microphone I
found someone who'll require your full
attention this monologue is very
reminiscent of the voicemails Elijah
leaves on David's answering machine in
unbreakable when he tries to encourage
him to embrace his superhero side all
right I do have a few more things you
missed but not a whole lot to say about
them the first is in this shot and while
we're focused on Elijah some dude gets
rekt by the Beast in the background
that's a super interesting choice to
have the action play out as a barely
noticeable background detail so I'm
interested to see how that plays out in
the actual movie then in this shot I
noticed David Dunn's son and Joseph
holding his arm as if he's an injured
Joseph always believed that his dad was
a superhero and there are a few
instances where he puts his dad in
dangerous situations to try to prove it
I have to wonder if he starts to believe
that he's inherited these same powers
and that's how he gets himself hurt or
if one of the bad guys targets him to
try to rattle David towards the end of
the trailer Elijah can be spotted
wearing this necklace with the initials
mg I'm assuming that stands for mr.
glass and if that's true then it seems
like a wise is really playing into his
supervillain persona then we've got a
shot of kc cook from split getting off
this bus and this is actually the same
bus that david gets off in his
neighborhood in unbreakable now it's
hard to say if that's an actual
reference to unbreakable or if this is
just a common bus line in Philadelphia
so if any of you guys are from Philly
feel free to let me know in the comments
so I've got several videos in the
pipeline right now as I mentioned that
this is probably the last of the October
uploads I know I had also expressed
interest in doing an episode on the
happy deathday to you trailer that's
because I thought it was out already but
they haven't actually put it online yet
despite the fact that it's playing in
front of Halloween in theaters right now
I would like to wait for that to come
out on YouTube before I do the things
you
episode and I know there have been a lot
of things you missed lately and there is
a reason for that a lot of you have been
asking where the next called ain't a
creepypasta is for those of you who
don't know that's my scary story
narration series I've got some new
episodes plans so that should be back on
soon as well and I have decided to do a
little marathon leading up to the
release of glass I'll be doing a things
you missed on unbreakable and split so
if you are a fan of this thriller horror
series which I'm imagining you are if
you made it this far in the video then
remember to subscribe to seize these
worlds for new Horrors every week ring
that death bell for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one
assuming you both survive